let's move on to our headlines number
one Donald Trump is pushing for schools
to be reopened in the fall the media
Democrats course are saying that Trump
is trying to kill our kids and and
that's what Jennifer Rubin the
Washington Post's major scare quotes
here conservative op-ed writer said on
Twitter that Donald Trump wants to kill
your kids verbatim that's what you said
because he wants to reopen schools yet
the interesting thing is that none of
the people so far as I can tell who now
insist on schools being closed for
coated insisted on the same during flu
season the flu even with a vaccine is
more deadly to kids than kovat but
nobody ever says close the schools
during flu flu season every once in a
while you hear about an individual
school shutting down for a few days
because of a really bad outbreak in that
you know in that locality but you never
have anything like a nationwide shutdown
during flu season why on one hand you
have a contagious disease that rarely
causes serious complications or death in
children but sometimes does on the other
hand you have a contagious disease that
even more rarely causes serious
complications or death in children but
an even more rare circumstances
sometimes does why would we shut down
schools for the latter but not the
former it makes no sense unless of
course shutting down schools has nothing
to do with health and is more about
politics and narrative which obviously
is the case here number two a politician
in oregon received a disturbing deeply
disturbing racist letter last week of
went viral on Facebook was covered by
the news media really rough stuff that
in this letter racist letter the only
problem is that the politician Jonathan
Lopez wrote it himself
shocker of all shockers the twist ending
no one saw coming so after a few days he
admitted yeah he wrote it himself just
for fun let's read the letter that
Lopez's alter-ego sent to himself the
letter says Mr Lopez you're not welcome
here and we'll never be anything in this
community or state don't waste your time
trying to become anything in this
country we will make sure you never win
and your family suffers along with all
the other
effing Mexicans in the area sincerely
America
sincerely America once again the hoaxers
are just having a lot of trouble coming
up with a believable script for their
imaginary racists which just shows you
like we talked about all the time you
know if this is such a racist country
why are why are people constantly having
to invent these these instances of
racism but even more than that not just
that it's being invented but if it's
such a racist country like you would
think that someone like jonathan lopez
would have encountered racism in the
past and so he could write a believable
script of what a racist would say to him
but he's not he's going based on what he
sees in the movies and TV shows and so
that finally kept speaking of
implausible events by the way while
we're on the subject of dubious hate
crimes there was a very strange hate
crime incident reported a few weeks ago
that you may have heard about a few
weeks ago you probably haven't heard
about in the last two weeks because
strangely enough it disappeared from the
headlines but here's the report that ABC
did on the story back on on June 26
watch this while waiting for a green
light this is where Althea Bernstein
says four white men yelled a racial slur
at her before attacking her and setting
her on fire with lighter fluid Michael
Johnson with the Boys and Girls Club
says he can't think of a more obvious
instance of a hate crime and so she has
bars to her face bars to her neck
Johnson speaking on behalf of the
Bernstein family says Althea is
physically doing well today because her
mom and her dad is concerned about you
know her mental well-being and scars I
saw on her Bernstein told Madison 365
Wednesday that the attack happened early
Wednesday morning at around 1:00 she
says she was at the intersection when
four white men and floral shirts yelled
the N word sprayed her with lighter
fluid and then threw a lit lighter at
her and here's a young lady was minding
her own business and somebody decided it
tried to set her on fire and it's
it's it's unacceptable Madison Police
say they are investigating this as a
hate crime
Johnson says this is an escalation of
racial tensions felt all across the
country that somebody tried to cause
bodily harm to somebody because of the
color of their skin and you know all of
these things that's happened across our
country right here in our backyard it's
just unacceptable and where's the
respect for Humanity okay and here are
the burns that she allegedly suffered
from having her face set on fire you see
it there
so she says she was at a red light 1:00
in the morning a roving band of racists
in Hawaiian shirts ran up with lighter
fluid and a match and a lighter rather
sprayed her the lighter Fleury face then
threw a lighter into the car a lighter
that stayed lit as it was thrown somehow
so must been one of those old fashioned
ones that you people use in the movies
and then her face was set on fire
oddly her hair was not damaged though
her face was on fire her hair didn't
catch somehow and then the racist
disappeared to this point we have seen
no video of this even though it happened
in an intersection in the city there's
no video no surveillance video that
we've seen there are no other witnesses
of this there's a gang of murderous
flame wielding Hawaiians sure did race
as' walking through the street
apparently not noticed by anyone else
and even though they're patrolling the
streets lighting women on fire nobody
else reported a violent encounter with
them or any other kind of encounter hmm
and those injuries you know is that what
your face looks like after being set on
fire I don't know my face has never been
so on fire but is that it's it that's a
it's a very those are very strange burn
marks considering what she claims
happened and also where is the lighter
that they threw shouldn't she have that
because they threw in [ __ ] I mean she
should have it and and they're their
prints on it but she never mentioned
having the lighter and she never showed
a picture of that and then what
damage to her car you know if she's on
fire in her car there should at least be
some fire damage around you know around
maybe the doorframe maybe on the on the
roof of the car but we never saw a
picture of that either and and here's
another strange thing there was there
was arson there was there was arson
going on that night confirmed arson
leftist rioters were setting buildings
on fire in the city and that was on the
same night that this supposedly happened
so she comes home with mysterious burn
marks the same night that arsonists are
running through the street and she tells
a story about flame throwing racists who
nobody else ever saw and who apparently
evaded detection by every video camera
in the city hmm number three campus
reform did one of those classic dumb
people on the street videos this time
asking mostly college aged kids it looks
like questions about July 4th and why we
celebrated and no surprise a bunch of
people didn't know a damn thing about
July 4th or why we celebrated or or
about American history but the really
disturbing part of the video is this
actually very to interesting people to
talk to we're teachers so I was a
seventh grade civics teacher government
teacher and she is an elementary school
teacher 4th grade 2nd grade elementary
school teacher what year did we get our
independence seventeen something I
personally know firsthand that we are
not getting taught specifically in
social studies the history that we need
to know I actually don't teach what's in
our curriculum I'm teaching children
social studies that's not in our
curricula I'm teaching them things about
how to be an anti-racist instead of
teaching those same three famous black
people that we continue to teach I
taught them about protesting I taught
them about black lives matter I taught
them about things that are happening
currently so that they could make those
connections and when they see it on the
news they're informed they're not
ignoring the facts of our world right
now there are facts that were actually a
racist country okay so those are the
people that are teaching our kids which
puts this
part of the video into perspective so
with the 4th of July coming up we're
gonna ask a couple questions my first
question for you guys is what does the
4th of July commemorate day we declared
independence from Great Britain
basically America's birthday right
a independence what year did we declare
our independence I'm gonna be real cute
I don't know 1967 Aussie clothes 1859
1964 I'm gonna give you a try what do
you think what year did we get our
independence 1970 something 74 is
something like that
1979 like the eighteen hundred's 1864
yes it's further back from 80 hundreds o
1777 yes that's a shock or is it that's
is impossible to figure out how that
could happen who could connect these
dots I don't know you've got teachers
one of whom teaches civics teaches
government doesn't know the date of our
independence somehow and then another
one who confesses that she doesn't even
follow a curriculum all she does is
teach about why racism is bad and then
you've got a bunch of kids who are
absolute morons and know nothing about
this country or its history how could
that happen I don't I just I don't get
it but let's continue sending our kids
to public school anyway sounds like a
great plan number four the ACLU is
calling attention to the case of Wesley
perky who's a 68 year old man with
Alzheimer's and other mental illnesses
who's also on death row and scheduled to
be executed in a week I think on July
15th he's gonna be executed the ACLU
says this is a terrible injustice the
media agrees Newsweek has a long article
about poor Wesley poor ol Wesley just a
nice old man gonna be killed by the
state poor guy right but the interesting
thing is that is that Newsweek has this
entire article talking about the poor
old man and how he's gonna be executed
and he doesn't understand why but
the entire article they never mention
what he did to land on death row in the
first place it's not until you get to
the very bottom in a bracketed editor's
note where it happens to mention what
the old man did to land himself on death
row I'll tell you what he did he
bludgeoned an 80 year old paralytic
woman to death with a hammer and he
kidnapped raped murdered and dismembered
a teenage girl so this is a guy who did
the worst thing imaginable and followed
it up with the other worst thing
imaginable he is Alzheimer's are not a
horrific ly evil monster unfit for human
society and I think that point is
relevant I think in a civilized society
this should be quite simple you rape and
murder a child you die you bludgeon an
old woman to death you die that's all
there is no extenuating circumstances
that should change the consequence of
that action there are some things a
person can do that forfeit their right
to be a part of human society in any
capacity even in prison and this is one
of those things and in fact he did two
of those kinds of things and you know
the great thing is it's not a high bar
to get over right don't-don't-don't rape
and murder and dismembered on't bludgeon
all women to death if you can't manage
to get over that bar if that's too high
a standard for you as a person then you
just shouldn't be living anymore and and
it is an undue burden on society to keep
you alive and house you and shelter you
and feed you nobody should have that
responsibility for you you have made it
clear you do not want to be a part of
society anymore and you should be simply
given your wish you know I think that
that the ACLU says that's not justice I
think that's like the very definition of
justice if you ask me
number five finally the Green Party of
Delaware tweeted this I don't know what
it is or why it is or
anything but I know that it is anyway
and here it is it's a picture of a woman
embracing a dolphin and the caption says
their dolphin human baby is the future
of intelligent life on earth and it's
the only way we'll let dolphins in some
form survive this is from the verified
account of the Green Party of Delaware
which granted it's the Green Party and
it's Delaware so there's probably three
members but still it appears that the
Green Party at least in Delaware is now
advocating for a very specific form of
bestiality which is which is may be
notable I have to say though I object on
moral grounds and also on every other
ground and on for the record I object
not just on the ground but in the sea
too but I also have to admit that a
dolphin human hybrid baby would
certainly give your life porpoise
so
I had to do it I'm sorry no I'm not
sorry I just said I won't apologize I
will not apologize especially for a for
a well-timed
bestiality pun I I just won't that I
won't apologize for this video is
sponsored by blink sale the
revolutionary invoicing software for
contractors and small businesses spend
less time billing and more time making
bank with blink sale get a free trial at
the link in the video description